this guy is uh named slug slug created
space war
if you go to the computer history museum
on most weekends slug will come and kick
your ass on the machine behind him which
is the machine that space war was
invented on in 1951 61 my apologies so
you can go there in 1961 and the guy who
invented that computer history will come
and kick your ass
this is very important because that is
how constricted our online history is
like the web is this little you know
when i say it the web is an eye blink in
the history of humanity right it's like
5 000 years from like oh my god a rock
to kim kardashian and then it's
it's like one millisecond to this right
and and and also i for some people who
care there's no hover hand i touched him
i touched the man i love him
again life is a lossy format but
software is not quite a lossy format it
likes to be completely together and
that's where luck comes in so there's a
thing i've been working on for about
three years this is what i started
working on when brewster hired me one of
the things he said to me was
i would like for you you know we've been
doing pretty good with web we've been
okay with the web we've been pretty good
books we're actually doing good with
music we have a lot of music
we have a whole lot of movies but what
about software how do we do things with
software and the reason that movies and
music persist is because we can play
them and not only can we play them but
we can play them like nothing like if
i'm like oh god listen how terrible this
band is
the time from man
what are you talking about too you're
right they suck can be like five seconds
right that's amazing isn't that amazing
like you forget it like oh my god look
what this cat is doing on top of writing
this this roomba boom you're looking at
cat on roomba the world's a little
dumber but you did it two seconds and so
why don't we have that with software
this is the moment when my mind got
blown right
this is a game called um
smurf rescue from colecovision right
let's go back to it and
in it you pilot a smurf he has to jump
over those things and meet smurfette
it's very simple it's for the
colecovision but over the course of two
and a half years we got it to run in the
browser in javascript
and here's the thing about that why like
first of all why would you do that
abomination against all of man and lord
and anyway so the thing is is that right
now the way to get to everybody is the
web the way that we get there is using a
browser and the thing in browsers that
has not been destroyed by larry ellison
is
javascript
right javascript's in everything like it
or not and technology has been done to
turn javascript into the end run for a
compiler without going into the full
technical details because they're all up
there the point is we were able to take
a emulator called mess the
multi-emulator super system that has 1
600 platforms
everything from sega genesis and 2600
to the glicovision and be able to make
it play stuff in your browser basically
in full speed the first time we got it
running it ran at 14 speed we had it in
70 speed within two weeks we had 24
systems running at 100 speed and it's
gone on like that right um we have been
able to do all these different systems
um we have old stuff from atari all
these are running in javascript here's a
chess system from 1979 here's spy versus
spy we've even gotten to the point you
know that's that's neat and it's up
there if you go to archive.org go to
software boom you could say to somebody
i can't believe someone made a game
about this there it is
okay
so
from there it gets really weird and
scary
because now once we've been able to make
a machine run in a machine
where do you go from there well um we
have something i call the emularity this
is uh windows running inside of a
browser
um and we actually have it booting up
so that's javascript and we've actually
gotten ppp to work so that the browser
can connect through ppp out of the
browser into the internet
so it's connecting the textfiles.com
using the mosaic the the mosaic browser
um and is able to connect so it's a
1994 browser inside of a 1993 operating
system that's running inside of a
2015 browser that's running inside of a
operating system right
we're here now
um
now just to be clear the current
internet does not like you
uh whitehouse.gov is like what are you
forsooth i cometh with the magna carta
to bring us to you
um but that's what we you know so okay
fine i understand that but the best part
is it actually leaves something in the
log so it'll actually say well 16-bit
windows 3-1 netscape 1.0 is stopped by
that'll blow your metrics right the heck
out
[Music]